>> That's right David and that means that means-ends analysis doesn't not
always take us to what's the goal. Sometimes it can take us away from the goal.
And sometimes means-end analysis can get caught in loops. Means-end analysis,
like genetic and test, is an example of universal error methods.
These universal error methods are applicalbe to very large classes of problems.
However, they can rate few guarantees of success, and
they're often very costly. They're costly in terms of computational efficiency.
They neither provide any guarantees of computational efficiency, nor
provide any guarantees of the optimality of the solution that they come up with.
Their power lies in the fact that they can be applied to a very large class of
problems. Later in this class, we'll discuss problem-solving methods,
which are very specialized problem-solving methods.
Those methods are applicable to a smaller class of problems. However,
they are more tuned to those problems and often are more efficient and
sometimes, also provide guarantees over the optimality of the solution.
Although means-end analysis did not work very for this problem. It in fact works
quite well for many other problems and therefore is an important AI method.
Later in this class when we come to planning, we will look at more powerful
specialized methods that can in fact address this class of problems quite well.